hey leute bevor es mit dem video losgeht
muss ich noch keine ankündigung machen
und zwar habe ich mit max valier in
italien war mikroskopisch und ich hatte
dann beim aufnehmen weil drei folgen die
sind ganz doofen fehler jetzt ist die
audio naja ich sage es mal so bescheiden
seid mir nicht böse ich brauche die
folgen dringend weil ich gern vor
produzieren wir das ist echt ein
zeitdruck komme beziehungsweise gar
nicht schaffe ich würde sagen macht die
audio einfach so weit leiser das mich
gerade noch so versteht dann ist es
eigentlich in ordnung und ja falls euch
auch die qualität absolut wichtig ist
dann überspringt die folgen und wartet
auf die nächsten 12
dafür aber ich kann es leider nicht mehr
ändern ich hoffe es ist in ordnung für
euch und ich würde sagen ja jetzt zum
video viel zu große teams in 64 des
wagens wir spielen heute auf tatooine
wollen heute sogar mit 20 mal in einer
partie und treffpunkt ist wieder oben
ich wollte mir eine kleine feine
behinderte community aktion
ob es ihn seine mutter stören würden
wir müssen aber mit aufgeführt wird
okay aber ich habe mich wirklich so
klein nein niemals
doch nicht bei uns heiß begehrt
auch auf lecks reflexiv die hdj an den
reflex youtube hd soll das heißen
hdmi youtube von reflex wenn ihr
abschreibung leute die eigentlich change
ist ja nicht dabei die runde will
sondern die frage ist wie viele leute
kann man durch bringt ich glaube dass
angriffe vor wollen kann es seien noch
eine bogen wollte ein schöner großer
spieler
mal kurz topmanagern damit wir uns hier
abstimmen kann
ein episches aragon ist der store ist
der rest ist weiß jeder was geht ok gut
so selber leute genauso viel zu viel
immer wissen doch zu viel übrig sein
zu viel zu viel chaos okay leute folgen
einfach mal wild mal ne runde mit ihrer
runde und wir schauen erst mal wo
potenzielle gegner sind weil ich glaube
ich dass man kompass arbeiten können
ganz ehrlich so viele leute habt ihr
dann alle raus kommen sehen nein
optisch fall schaden optisch gleicht
highschool bt
aber das wird nicht funktionieren
also ich beim ersten spot läuft sich
jetzt das mal keine gegner also die
wussten sich wieder dunkel wichtig sein
können sein
klassiker
das war kurz schauen welche gegner wir
noch haben also hier zum zombie games
ist ein gegner bergriesen gegner und
just lehre axt und sex dass unser
einziger noch viel gegner glaube ich
okay berg situationen gegenseitig jetzt
haben wir noch leere jagst und sex als
gegner und vor und zombie gezockt wie
erbsen ich habe mich aber auch nicht zu
essen wenn alle
wisst ihr was sie machen den wir müssen
das mit komm wir machen es einfach
gleich mal eine playlist das management
nicht sein dass hinter diesen gegner das
geht nach unten
der sex bringt einmal weil ich bevor ich
aber erstmal das war für uns alle geht
das alles zieht man uns ich hoffe mein
kompass nach einkommen
ich würde man es nicht zeit muss
scheinen zumindest dass angelina sie
nämlich durch der klinik knast weil es
spart ich weiß wo sie den 25
oha facetten oder gibts ja nicht dabei
gilt es ja nicht
es gibt es nicht doch mit gilt ergebnis
neuss
perry sie recht aber die masse nix heute
36 ich würde sagen wenn ich so folge
gefallen
22 da muss mir jetzt noch keinen gp
verlassen wir sind in der nächsten folge
was ich sagen soll besser vom kopf ab
und an